another big performance in Kenyan Drake
arrived via page right okay they got
David Johnson to paint him all that
money can't wait to be a free agent then
I'm gonna be able to keep him because
they got all the money tied up in David
Johnson
well yeah crazy right we got a look at
David Johnson's contract you're stuck
within or stuck next Reacher yeah Wow
yeah that's that they're paying whether
he's there or not it's like ten million
price next year that already has vested
fully guaranteed for David Johnson Wow
yeah they got a problem yeah they do the
Seahawks have a problem they don't have
any running backs I mean this the
Cardinals have too many the Seahawks
don't have enough Rashad Penny was
already on injured reserve
there's Carson's now out for the season
right CJ Prosise injured again shocker
yeah really since Marshawn Lynch they
have yet to find a guy who can stay
healthy wire-to-wire and wouldn't it be
great if they brought back Marshawn
Lynch for week 17 pass whatever test he
would have to take but but there's
concern there
Travis Homer because he's the guy who
had the fake punt against the Vipers
that he ran for the first down twenty
nine yards I think it was yeah he
becomes their their lead tailback for
week 17 Sunday night football against
the 49ers with the division title on the
line yeah well he's got potential I'll
say that I really liked him coming out
of the draft at a University of Miami
he's a smaller guy but like sticks his
foot in the ground and can go to 0 to 60
in like three steps so that's exciting
from that standpoint but the injuries at
the running back position listen CJ I
mean when when Pro stood up bro yeah
when Carson Rashard Penny first went
down I was concerned you knew about that
because this is not a team that's overly
creative on the offensive side of the
ball they need some of those talented
guys who can make plays when nothing's
there now for him to go down now two
other running backs go down
yeah I'm major concerned about the
Seattle Seahawks I mean there's no doubt
about that one as we've seen in some of
these Seattle struggles see Seattle's
offense is just not overly creative with
the schematics of the pass game you've
heard me say this for the last two years
a lot of it is just go straight run deep
you know deep post you know post corner
corner post straight go Rao and rustle
just hit you off a play action and
that's the way we'll do it well you know
that's not always gonna work if you
can't dominate the line of scrimmage and
run the football and that's the problem
Seattle's gonna have right now let alone
Seattle's defense let's not even get
into that you know as we've seen here
you know if Jadeveon Clowney is not in
the lineup to kind of ruin the game plan
for the opposing offense up front they
can be exposed at all every level of
their defense so you know again I
Seattle's tough they're gonna compete
it's hard for me to look at them right
now and think they advert least for my
money they think they have a legit
chance to go to the Super Bowl this year
Travis Homer is backed up or will be
backed up unless they bring in a Sean
Lynch or someone else by Xavier Turner
from the practice squad from Tarleton
State University a member of the Texas
A&M University System and I will admit
until two minutes ago I had never heard
you never heard I knew a Tarleton just
from being down there is it Tarleton or
tarlatan
I thought it was Tarleton I don't know I
just I know how to say it either but
yeah I mean that's just and we what is
the precise like prognosis have we heard
that yet as far as like is he definitely
out for the playoffs is he have a chance
to come back I think he's out for next
week I know he's out for the season
Browns out for the season to or at least
out good luck passing the ball good luck
stopping Nick Bosa know there's a lot of
issues with the Seattle Seahawks team
this is a Seattle Seahawks team that hey
I give them a lot of credit they're 11
and 4 but let's not forget every game
they've played is like a one score game
they're not blowing anybody out this is
not the way they play
you know they've won games because you
know usually Pete Carroll manages the
game the right way they're tough they
compete and then Russell Wilson makes a
few plays down the stretch that's what
they do and I don't know if Russell
Wilson even as awesome as he is is gonna
be good enough to overcome this right
here against the an you know I'm talking
I'm holding them up to the NFC elite I
know they're really good because I have
been all year but thing is you're right
they're not they're not dominant and now
they're injured yeah they're back
there's indeed out for the year they're
gonna have a problem and that by week is
so critical for whoever wins that
division they don't need that week off
whether it's 49ers with the Seahawks
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports